I just heard of getting a blood test for Galactin 3.
Is this something that we should track?
Well, it can be, and we do have that blood test
available in the lab store.
It's through, I think it's through Boston Labs, does it?
And you could order it.
It's not super expensive.
It's like, I want to say it's about 35 bucks or something like that.
Galactin 3 is an enzyme in your body.
And it can be the higher levels.
I think the normal Galactin 3, you want to keep it under like 17.
If it's in the high teens or in the 20s,
that high level of Galactin 3 leads to ill health, not just cancer.
But it was initially information about Galactin 3 was about heart disease.
And it was used as a marker to show up a person had a heart attack or not.
But now it's been implicated in other diseases.
It can be high at all immune disease.
It certainly can be high in cancer.
And if you can get your Galactin 3 levels down, it's been shown in some studies and hypothesized
with different doctors, you're going to have, you're going to fare much better.
How do you get Galactin 3 levels down?
Well, again, the biggest thing is supporting all your detox pathways.
So I don't know, Dr. Isaacs is big into modified centrospectin.
And I've been big into modified centrospectin as well.
I write about Galactin 3 in most out fighting cancer book.
And we recommend modified centrospectin for a lot of people.
From a nutritional standpoint, keylators, anything that's going to help support liver detoxification
is going to help reduce collective three levels.
Modified centrospectin is one of those keylators that has been shown time to time again to be one of the best things to bring down collective three levels.
Do you have to measure it?
That is, there's some disagreement in philosophies about that because you can do a measurement of Galactin 3 on some of US stage for breast cancer.
And they're collected three levels are way below normal.
So the idea is, well, then that's not an issue, but it can be an issue even if somebody's collected three levels are below normal because it depends on how they're expressed in the tissue.
In question, so when you're only, when you're measuring Galactin 3, you're measuring blood levels, it can be different in the tissue.
So, now I would say that if a person has elevated collected three levels in the blood, then most likely they have elevated 3 levels in the tissue.
But I would say that elevated collected three levels in the blood are more indicative of heart issues and epithelial damage than they are as being a bigger player with the cancer.
I typically don't have it recommended people doing a test.
Just take modified citrospectrum, just work of your liver detox pathways.
So that goes, you know, we've done that with really every cancer patient, not maybe they're not all a modified citrospectrum, but literally everybody was working on their detox pathways.
But you can run the test, it's an inexpensive test to run.
But remember, Galactin 3 is a target protein, it will go up with inflammation and it will change quite quickly.
That's the other negative about measuring it. If you're in a state of inflammation, let's say you're, let's say it's your epithelial tissue or your cancer that is currently inflamed, your Galactin 3 levels will go up.
Well, literally, if you call it down with other means, it can change in a matter of hours.
So the blood test is, is, can jump all over the place.
And that's why a lot of doctors don't like to even measure it.
Because it can be high and then you can run it the next day and it can be low.
And it's like, so it's in a good marker looking at the blood levels. It's questionable. I know there's argument.
It's certainly spark a person if it's high to do something about it, but it can also give a person a false like, oh, I'm fine, I'm doing really good.
But if it's with the normal or it's low, so positive negative to every test.
But that's the, that's what the measure is up to three.
Versus like two markers, I mean, two markers can, can spike with the cancer growing, but it's not going to change day by day.
You're going to see two markers go up and the cancer is growing and, you know, they'll, they can go up sharply.
But then you run it, if you run another blood test, the next week, they're not going to go down sharply.
Well, you can see that my collected three and it can be a little bit confusing.